l attenti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj scusate un attimo
ragazzi prima di partire volevo soltanto
scusarmi perché in realtà questo blog si
è sposato completamente l'audio perché
questo bellissimo microfono questo
microfoni ma perché ciò è già una
levetta che sarebbe questa che quando la
premi si sente tutto di merda e lo so
ragazzi prima che io ok durante blog
tenuto premuto stanne vetta quai non me
ne sarà accolta ovviamente con ragazzi
scusatemi se in questo blog si sente
male più anzi vicente peggio del solito
si capisce ma sempre un po peggio e
niente volevo scusarmi soltanto per
questo è non capiterà più promesso ci
metto un tipo lo scotch adesso per
evitare di preme la levetta non prima di
averlo torturato ovviamente possiamo
cominciare bene tutti ragazzi e
benvenute questo video sono fan di j
oggi siamo in uno blog prima di
cominciare agazzi cosa dovrebbe partire
con la parte la settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da laura che ha
fatto la cosa è uscita meglio il
cappello che cosa di stampa l'art che ha
leggermente sarà nè tipo è il mio ciuffo
che abnorme sembra roba tipo
insomma c'è qualcuno che fa surf sul
cazzo di cioccolata con cavate
bellissima complimenti bravi bracco che
passando le news ragazzi e stavolta
mette da cintura di sicurezza anche se
non siete in macchina ve lo dico che
temesse la cintura che ti sto guardando
metti sta cazzo di ci metti sta cintura
la prima e non ragazzi qua credo che
esploda non sono un vulcano di fuori non
ha idea stanno facendo outlast 2
ok calde sento delle urla di stanno
facendo due che non ho idea di quando
uscirà me l'avete detto voi se andate a
controllare ed è vero che queste
riguarda la seconda news ragazza è
uscita il seguito di tre doubt quindi
come no non vi ricordate 3 doubt
ecco il gioco horror bello proprio da
bambino
1 quindi ragazzi è uscita sentito
l'inter ed alto quindi durante la
settimana cercherò di fare anche quello
e sarà una bomba pazzesca soprattutto
per il mio cuore ma quelli sono dettagli
e come molti ragazzi vi sono state ma
perché faccio sempre così quando dico
legnose tipo sembra che sto per prendere
il volo come ultima news e ragazzi
volevo dirvi che siccome avete chiesto
tutti quanti da quando ho fatto il
contest delle magliette la nintendo
ragazzi sta scegliendo i vincitori e le
magliette poi li invierà le magliette
con la firma per chi lo volesse sapere
perché molti mi avete scritto da fari e
magliette ci sta pensando la nintendo
quindi faranno tutto l'occhio ragazzi
non hanno da avrei mai avuto la forza di
decidere il vincitore perché per me le
fan art io quando sarò grande mela
riguardano tutte io ce l'ho tutti da
parte ragazzi poi la nintendo sceglierà
il vincitore però io scegli se io li
tengo lì proprio belli belfi ragazzi non
voglio scaraventarmi maroni con le news
e quindi passerà allo scart aggio di
pacchi madonna mia l'alzheimer ma vado a
prendere prima che impazzisco cosa che è
già successa vabbè allora facciamola
cosa ragazzi io lo so che è natale però
forti ma chi ammazza sì perché è questo
che insomma la mia maglia
ragazzi io non ho mai pensato a questa
cosa c'è vi rendete conto cioè inverno e
questi poveri pacchi sono nudi nudi ma
vi rendete conto come sono costretti a
vivere stipati qua
compriamo un maglione per i pacchi
hashtag salva il pacco anche tu fallo
non è una cosa normale non l'avrò per
ultimo questo cosa col maglione mi
sembra vi sembra troppo bello quello col
maglione prodotti o ragazzi parte con
comunque cos'è sta roba
siamo un panetto c'è anche un capello
incastrato c adesso questo lo prendo lo
manda alla cia
ok perfetto la partiamo con questo
perché c'è un pacco in un pacco mio di
sei serio e no è uno schiaffo a
giudicare dalla leggerezza e credo che
sia una presa per il culo ragazzi
provano ma io
fino all'ultimo ragazzi non si posso che
come sia presto tipo la prestige lato da
ragazzi aspettami evert bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye no ci sono dei
giornali di michela ne intende ha
iniziato a mettere dei giornali dentro
due di esse vi prego no no no una
[ __ ] roccia forse non tutto è perduto
magari la nintendo ha iniziato a
confezionare rocce quindi ditemi che
sono ancora un 2 di s sì sì cazzo un
pacchetto di fazzoletti boh mi mancava
questo grazie perfetto l'attenzione
ragazzi signore e signori
oh mio dio ce l'abbiamo pace manics
poche mani se poteva mese ma [ __ ]
sì posso che no dai seriamente spero che
chiunque vi abbia inviato questo pacco
gli arrivi per matare una playstation
fatta di cartone pietro e carta igienica
sporca con caricatore due di esse
ovviamente se non c'è il caricatore come
cazzo lo carico grazie hai pensato a
tutto proprio non ci ha fatto bene tra
l'altro c'è anche il film è così sottile
che si spezza con un grissino
dov'era il cappello di prima che mi
chiamo faccio arrestare dalle spiagge i
ragazzi o meno non ci ho più parole
manca moria cos'è sta roba
sono di sicuro di sé rayban questi
grazie di cuore no veramente non spacco
troppo degli occhiali roma perché ci
sono solo occhiali stoppa cobelli non
vedo un cazzo eroga bellissime dopo
questo e questo è bello non hayden che
cosa siamo gente mi sto innamorando di
sa cosa hai un pozzo telefono che fitto
ad esso possa portare in tutta
tranquillità gli hotel è bellissimo
credo che sia il sicura miot e proprio
smerda neanche un pochino fantastica e
adesso punto ragazzini passa dall ultimo
parco quindi quello vestito amico mio
verificasse sbagliati anche se inverno
però devo farlo abbi pazienza per
fermiamo al maltrattamento di pacchi
spogliati dai cos'è sta roba
oh mio dio giornata ok business del nes
qui
[Musica]
e comunque ragazzi a parte di switch
c'era anche questa ricevendo regali
prima di natale grazie ragazzi ha
chiesto alle spiega natale lo so che
avete chiesto tutti quanti quindi
smettetela di ieri no ma che cazzo ma è
una è una pietra antica cos'è sta cosa
ho trovato un fossile cos'è sta cosa che
puzzano e merda non ha capito no
sinceramente ha due tasti pure non so se
con secondo me questo sarà il congegno
per far esplodere il mondo quando ce ne
sarà bisogno
solo che ancora non lo sappiamo che mi
sono affidato nel medioevo quando apre i
miei pochi perché tutti e 33 questi
costi che cazzo la prossima volta ci
trovo neanderthal dentro a questo son
detta le e direi che possiamo passare al
farvi risponde la pillola ragazzi arriva
da demi grad mi fa vincere corti una
storia triste che questa l'avevo letta
su facebook qualche tempo fa però è
bello mi toccherà il cuore una volta c'è
un ragazzo chiamato bob bob bob non ha
le braccia
chi è di sicuro non è bob titolo che
state piangendo ciò già vivendo le
lacrime dalla webcam giudicare anche a
tali fa risponde trovo su google
cos'è sta roba ti divertirai comunque
sei un grande così stop ma si muove
[Musica]
ok cosa cazzo dovrebbe essere stato
variato bello se stesso formato si ferma
se continua ok ragazzi le discoteche non
esistono più fiori risponde favi lo sai
che c'è ancora gente che si permette di
chiamarti favi geico la giusta creata
maiuscola dalla quale gli ammazzerei nel
sonno c'è ancora gente che scappa vj con
la j mai più truci ma stiamo fa dj norma
fa dj e difficile all'essere umano cosa
cazzo perché ammettono la j staccata la
gente cioè prima e l'afa vj pre
diventato fa vj poi è diventato fari
staccato geni poi dal gei prenderà il
cazzo di decollo non lo so
la fia che mi chiama sono favi poi si
staccherà anche lei e [ __ ]
risponde se il nemico del mio amico è
mio nemico è il nemico del mio nemico è
mio amico l'amico del mio nemico che
cos'è è un testo di scavi 76 casi
l'unica persona al mondo a possedere il
prototipo del locus della samsung cai
vino che hai vino al fashion world
sì mi fa veramente strano letta sarebbe
questo praticamente l'uomo prototipo del
loculo swift della samsung l'unico tutto
problema è che non è uscito un cazzo di
gioco ancora quindi non è non c'è una
sega e se non c'è una sega secondo me
che cazzo sto vedendo io ditelo che sono
tremendamente sexy non vedo un cazzo con
questa roba non vede la [ __ ] ora di
farci un gameplay con qualcosa per che
però devono uscire i giochi prima perché
siccome sono solo io nel mondo non hanno
fatto i giochi e di sicuro non li faccio
il favismo ande fa viva al suo amico le
chiede il primo fan che incontri se
fossi qui come adesso mi faresti un
succhiotto sul collo spulciate sarà è
piceno devo andare il suo amico la di
resta cagata qui ma lei patisca allora
ragazzi ci sia bisogno davvero di non
beccare almeno non un maschio almeno
quello non scappare
mi capita un maschio ed è peggio ok sono
sistema ios e kakà alla camera a posto
ascoltami ti devi farmi un favore mi
hanno detto segar ma che vi cassa
vendendo un attacco di cordami che devo
fare è difficile anche per me darvi una
[ __ ] mano ci sei non sono un fake
non solo un fake guardami sono qui sono
fari jenny vedi ok il mo.vi la mano
nuovo anche il pene si è poi era cosa
del del fatto che muovo il premio di
proporre bici è difficile lo so però me
lo hanno chiesto e devo farlo
ascoltami ascoltami ascolta ascolta c6
adesso ti farò una domanda e tu mi devi
dare una risposta
ok se tu forse devi darmi la parola
risposta giavazzi e di vitalizio
mi faresti un succhiotto sul collo qua
come non lo so degli e di sé a scappato
è colpa vostra casa è colpa vostra
leggendo ragazzine che possono correre
qui questo bellissimo blog con un
bellissimo finale per ditelo che avete
pianto per bob ditelo perché lo scoop i
ragazzi la femmina e manda di oggi e che
cazzo è sta roba
voglio saperlo bilancio una pietra ho
dato una ginocchiata alla scrivania
adesso devo andare dal medico porca
[ __ ] che macrini ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto è se avete compassione per il
mio ginocchio lasciate un commento in
piace anche pace di facebook che come
noi video trattare tiziana sorsero essi
discovery ci mettiamo passione belle
ragazze
[Musica]